all right man bootleg cat podcast all
the way in the Bay Area
I came out here to [__] with my guy
burner man a special edition special
edition at your your first of all this
new compound you have
it is a man I wish well listen we're
gonna do a tour on the YouTube channel
so people will be able to see it but man
this [__] is crazy dog like this is some
real like uh as you would like to say
some real Mafia [__] it's like ghost
[__] dog like [__] we built everything
you've seen today from the house on the
couch in the front room pacing in the
house and so
you know landlords could be a pain in
the ass so I I wanted to wait to build
something like this until I was a
landlord until I could buy the building
and kind of decide what I want to do I
want to do it you know and just not have
to answer anyone I've seen a lot of big
businesses even in this area being
pushed out by their landlord yeah and
that [__] I would never do that ever I
was gonna say like you've always had
like you know you're always Diversified
to say the very least right but in terms
of like the content space you've always
you know I think back to the days where
you were like going viral on a world
star you know what I'm saying like for
Wild Things
all the way to now we're like you know
you've had a show like borders
Roundtable that was dope I I don't know
if you're bringing that back or not are
you planning on bringing them back yeah
you know like podcast for me is like a
little tough like it's just like um it's
kind of like you have to be really
consistent and you've been super
consistent so I give you props on that
but for me it's like
I think the cookings where the Hearts at
no for sure like and I really like a lot
of people like yo he's just doing a
cooking show and I see a lot of people
doing cooking shows and doing cooking
content but I grew up in the kitchen my
father had a restaurant growing up you
know that and there's a beast of a cook
he's a good cook and then um but I feel
like
besides the cooking show I think that
like we want to build like the urban
Food Network and that's what I'm trying
to do over here that's why you see this
building completely empty
um the warehouse you saw is completely
empty I'm trying to get some Capital
some serious Partners I understand the
vision
to kind of create like what we like to
watch on the Food Network I mean the
Food Network is dope I you we all get
stuck watching it for hours but it's
repetitive it's the same chefs Guy Fieri
shout out to him and it's for certain
like crowd it's a certain crowd but like
there's a whole world out there of like
viral Instagram chefs killing it there's
a whole world of like you know just the
black and brown Community doing their
thing and just in the food World it just
is being ignored by the mainstream
television so our goal is to to build a
networking so I said just like
podcasting is cool but
I'm in the bay one not many people rode
through here and two I don't really know
if I want to share this place with that
many people I kind of want to keep it
yeah if you have too many people coming
in and out like you said like this is a
special place it's it's pure right now
right you know I got to keep a little a
yada and I mean on my hip but that's
good with me like I don't want to have
full security now and not be able to
sleep but I like it the way it is now
and I think food content is pretty pure
yeah I was gonna say with the food [__]
so the goal in this like really is like
to eventually try to have a channel
that's on TV yeah you know
either like a channel on TV or like
building my own network that consists of
like a food segment of things like a
like a true crime series kind of you
know style content short films that we
debut I really want to build my own
network really yeah and I got some good
things going on
um we spoke about I don't know the last
time I have a scripted series and it
works a really big Network
and it's a big budget and I think it's
going to do really well and I feel like
while I'm in those doors you know me I'm
a wiggle I'm gonna get to know people
I'm gonna be able to shake hands rub
shoulders with the right people and I've
I feel like if I have a portfolio of
content that ranges from like the food
space to true crime documentaries
documentary yeah too you know the short
films that could be proof of concepts
for real films and maybe there's like a
network partnership or maybe there's a
partnership with like a bigger Network
or something like that so
I just kind of seen what 50 did I
respect the [__] out what he did but I
don't want to have to rely on like
networks the whole time I'd rather kind
of build my own portfolio in the
background and do a partnership with the
network of of content that I own and
produce myself I was gonna say I think
we had talked about you maybe doing a
movie or something that kind of covered
the bipin aspect of the bay yeah
actually my my partners in that the
script is done it's called uh it's
called a Splash City they're coming here
probably they'll probably be here in
like 30 minutes so as soon as we're done
with our interview and tour then I'm
gonna sit down with them review this
script but that script's ready
um there's another script ready as well
so yeah just you know taking my time to
[__] what it do right yeah I feel like
you know that is like one of the things
that like a soul Bay Area specific that
when I talk to people like
they don't know even they've never even
heard the word pimp and they're like
what the [__] is that like it's such a
they get here and they get their [__]
hit and I I feel like it's gonna be like
the new school New Jersey Drive almost
somebody yeah it's gonna be dope because
no one's really covering the Bay Area
and that's kind of my goal I feel like
all right I made it to a certain status
I feel like I put on hard with the music
as much as I could and I'ma still [__]
with it but I feel like my ultimate goal
is to kind of put the band my back in
the sense of telling some of these
stories yeah tapping into some of this
Untold content like no one's ever
attached to the Bay like all the crime
films and movies are based on New York
La Chicago Boston right yeah you know
like where's the Bay Area stories at
right and so I feel like I'm trying to
get into a position like financially
hence you know just respect wise where
people trust me with those stories
that'd be hard dude
um I haven't we haven't talked on camera
since you made the Forbes Magazine so I
just want to say congrats that [__]
thank you that [__] is pretty gnarly to
like be like like damn my boys are like
my friend is on the cover of Forbes you
know the cool thing about that it's like
there's people that are way richer than
me and there's people that have built
way bigger businesses but to touch that
cover is like every businessman
entrepreneur's dream yeah so I have guys
like worth like hundreds of millions of
dollars they'd be like dog you did it
I'm like bro you did it [__] no
you did it for real yeah you got it got
it right now liquid but yeah they just
think it's a it's a really cool thing to
come out of cancer and then touch that
cover and then get the ad age award and
get a couple other things that we got
like it's just really cool and it's just
good morale for like the kind of
industry I'm in I was gonna say how does
that change your life being on that
cover because I'm sure it makes people
look at you a lot different two ways
yeah no I mean one people put more
respect on the business conversations
but two everyone thinks you just got it
gotta got it like they just seen that
word like 400 million dollars oh
[__] you could tell me to give
you let me get a half a meal let me get
let me
behind my company I know you guys like
bro like yo like this this this
valuation that they're putting on me as
a person
um you know kind of like relies on the
businesses performing executing and like
you know exiting one day right that's
what the value of my business is and so
it's kind of put a lot of things in
perspective you see even the rich rapper
list that [__] was true either that [__]
is crazy fourth or fifth I wasn't before
crazy and then you put yourself next to
rappers like um [__] Dr Dre yeah Dr
Dre Jay-Z Kanye oh Diddy and like people
like man burns not really rapper like
wait a minute hold up I do got 49 albums
out I've been rapping since 2006. people
are saying well he got other businesses
whoa so is that one everybody else
everybody else got you know uh at a time
to rock and and you know Roc Nation and
I mean yeah
Ace of Spades whatever you call it the
same thing it's the same exact thing
except the differences I'm Mexican you
know [__] low-key underdog okay so
it's cool as [__] to see that they
recognize me on that list because that
list I always dreamed about
um about being on a list like that and I
always said that that that people are
overlooking what I built and I just
remember one day kind of just throwing a
fit on Twitter like man I wish they
would look at my [__] and someone
actually was like well I'd be down the
audio and that's a really deep audit
they have to look at everything that you
have your assets your businesses it's
like a real they can't just put that
[__] out to make the cash is it the cash
King's list is that what they call it
not just just uh hip-hop uh how you know
wealthiest whatever it may be
um top five wealthiest you know so they
did that and yeah that [__] hit so they
like really like they turn over all the
pages and look into your [__] for real
for real yeah they do like a real audit
of you for sure oh wow yeah so it ain't
no fugazi ass number going out there no
no hell no no that's that's a real
number it's a real situation it's a real
it's just all around real like they're
not gonna they're not gonna play you on
that like right they're not going to
play themselves it's real Publications
with real credible writers and just
you know they're they're not playing
they're not playing no games with that
list that list is very strategic it's
very they do a good job of due diligence
you know I have to have them talk to
like business managers and the people
that do my taxes and yeah that's just
real damn you're right talking to CPA
and all that [__] CPAs are looking at
like properties they're looking at the
actual like oh you say your business
worth this like let's let's do actual
audit of your business let's do it you
know let's get a proper of what what did
you raise that last time you raised you
know like it's it's real as [__]